opérations pour la Syrie on a des
opérations pour la Turquie et là cette
première semaine après le tremblement de
terre notre objectif c'est de venir en
aide d'un côté à travers un volet
médical et de l'autre côté fournir des
tout ce qui est matériel de première
nécessité donc de couverture des kits
d'hygiène
[Musique]
l'autre problème qui va se poser c'est
que là il y a un gros focus sur tous les
ce qu'on appelle les 3 mois donc les
gens qui ont des fractures mais les
soins de santé risque de négliger toutes
les autres malades c'est-à-dire les gens
qui ont des problèmes de maladie
chronique qui en gros risque qui est un
déséquilibre au niveau de la fournisseur
des soins de santé